carl that is what they call a caller  scholar  and i knew the second they admitted you  to this beautiful facility that someday  you'd find a way to discharge your  weapon inside  thank you both of you what for  how much time you got henry  so are you ready to see marlowe  question is is she ready to see me oh i  think she's  ready to see you oh here i made her go  away  i know you did i couldn't stand the  thought of her seeing me like this one  more day  stuck in that bed and stuck in his chair  that woman is the greatest thing that's  ever happened to me i agree to  agree  hello my love  stop please  i'm sorry did i  [Music]  ah  [Music]  i just wanted to look my wife in the eye  when i said let's go home  i love you so much  [Music]  back up  [Music]  [Music]  you